these classes related to software and
statistics
and one of the topics i teach is
survival analysis so let's get into that
if you joined the slack channel
you will find a link there
that goes to this page which is the home
page for the tutorial
and you will find two things there
one of them is this link which will be
my slides i'll be presenting them but if
you have the slides up on your screen
that can be useful if you get ahead or
or behind you can catch up and then
we're going to work in two jupiter
notebooks today the notebooks run on
collab so you don't need to install
anything when we get to the notebooks
you can come back to this page and click
on the links or there are also links in
the slides as we go along
so i'm going to start here in the slides
i'll present for a few minutes and then
we'll get into the first notebook
if you have any technical problems uh
let us know on slack that's the best
place to put questions uh please don't
use the zoom chat just because there are
too many channels to keep track of and
i'll pause every once in a while to
check and see if we have questions and
answer things if you didn't get the link
on slack you can also use this url
allendowney.com
sap for
survival analysis in python
and that will take you to the same page
where again you'll get the slides and
the notebooks
so let's get into it survival analysis
is vastly under-appreciated
and i have to say that on my first slide
because i tweeted about this workshop a
couple of weeks ago
and the first response i got
was from anurag who said survival
analysis is vastly underappreciated and
i decided that that has to be my first
slide so
so that's why it was the first slide and
let me explain what i mean by that
if you do statistics major you might
take a class on survival analysis either
as an advanced elective or maybe a
graduate course and it's generally
considered to be a specialty within
biology or or medicine and i think
that's not right
it's not really a domain it's not
biomedicine it is a set of related
questions that apply in a lot of domains
and it's a set of methods in particular
for dealing with censored data and i
will explain what that means
so it's a set of related questions and
it tends to be about events that occur
usually in time although you can also do
this in space but let's we'll focus on
time and you might wonder how long will
it be until an event occurs or for a
recurring event how many times it might
occur during an interval
or the possibility that it will never
happen and you might want to put
probabilities and probability
distributions on all of these things
the other kinds of questions that you
can answer are
when is an event most likely to happen
and we we're going to describe that with
a hazard rate which is the likelihood
of an event
and what are the factors that might make
events more or less likely so if you're
thinking about medicine for example what
are the factors that might contribute to
a longer or shorter survival time
but this is not just biomedicine in fact
survival analysis
is the name in biomedicine but in other
fields it just goes by different names
so in engineering it's reliability
theory in economics duration modeling in
sociology event history analysis
and it comes up in business as well
there are a lot of models of customer
behavior for example a churn model would
describe the time until a customer might
leave and no longer be your customer or
might return
and there are recurring models that are
called the buy till you die
models that are also based in survival
analysis
so i claim that this is a useful thing
the other question that i got on twitter
is will we use a package like lifelines
or actually implement the algorithm
during the session
and the answer is both so this is the
outline for the talk we're going to
start out with kaplan-meier estimation
which is one of the fundamental tools of
survival analysis
and then we'll switch over to using a
python module called lifelines which is
a very nice library i written by cameron
davidson pilon who
has pulled together
a lot of really good methods
for survival analysis and also some
really nice documentation so this is
going to be my recommendation after this
workshop if you want to learn more that
will be your next stop and i'll have
some links for you at the end
so that's the outline i'm going to start
by describing survival and hazard
functions using a simple example as i
said kaplan-meier estimation and then
lifelines
let me present a motivating example at a
high level and then we'll get down into
the details
this is from a talk that i did in 2015
that was called will millennials ever
get married which is a deliberately
provocative title i'm not really making
fun of millennials uh if you're curious
about this topic there's a link here
which goes to my blog which is called
probably overthinking it and i wrote an
update on this article using new data
that was released in 2020
this is from the national survey of
family growth this is run by the
national center for health statistics
which is part of the cdc
and the as i said the the 2019 data was
released in 2020
and what i studied was the time until
first marriage for both men and women
grouped by decade of birth so that we
can see generational changes
and this is one of the figures that i
generated these show survival curves
where survival here means time until
first marriage what what age were the
respondents uh when they first got
married
and this is broken up by decade of birth
so at the bottom of the graph for
example that purple line
shows for women born in the 1940s
and we can pick a point on this curve
what it shows is the percentage who had
never married that is to say that they
have survived without being married at a
given age so at age 20 oops let me back
up at age 20
women who were born in the 1940s about
50 of them had been married so you can
read the median off this graph 50 were
married before age 20.
if you take a vertical slice out of this
graph so this dashed line is at age 28
and what this shows is that for women
who were born in the 1940s
it looks like only about 15 of them were
unmarried at age 28 that is to say the
vast majority of them had been married
before that age
but that has been changing from one
generation to another
quite dramatically so for women let's
pick the blue line here that's for women
born in the 1960s
at age 28 it looks like there were still
about 30 or 35 percent of them
um who were who had never been married
and if we now get to the most recent
generation that we have data for women
who are born in the 1990s we only have
data for them that goes up to about age
28 and at age 28 it looks like about 75
percent of them
are unmarried
so these are pretty dramatic
generational
uh changes
this is the same graph for men
the data don't go back quite so far in
time because this survey didn't start
collecting data for men until later
but we have data again for men who were
born in the 1990s and again we see the
same kind of generational change
but not quite as dramatic
so that's an example of survival
analysis and in particular the graphical
representation there is the survival
curve it shows the fraction of people
who have survived up to a particular
point in time
now here's the challenge with working
with data like this
at any point in time if you go out and
do a survey and you observe a cohort of
people
you'll find that some are married and
some are unmarried
for the ones who are married you know
their time until event you know their
duration
um because you know when they were born
and you know when they were married
if someone has not married yet
you don't know when they will get
married in the future
but you can put a lower bound on it so
if they're 25 years old now you can say
okay well i know that they will not get
married prior to age 28 25 but they
might get married after age 25.
so the goal of this analysis is to take
these two kinds of data and combine them
into a single estimate for the
distribution
this problem is called censored data if
you interview someone and they have not
been married yet
it is as if their the future data
has been
removed you are not allowed to know
things about the future and so
metaphorically at least we call that
censored data in this particular example
it is right censored which means that
it's the right-hand side of the timeline
that is getting cut off
so here's our goal we're going to
develop
ways of describing survival in terms of
survival curves and hazard curves which
i'll define in a minute and ways of
working with censored data of this kind
so we will get to it and dive into the
first notebook
if you are following along in the slides
there will be a link and if you go back
to the home page there will be a link
i'll give you a quick outline of what
we're going to do
in the first notebook we're going to
consider
the simpler case
where we have a representative sample of
lifetimes that is to say for notebook 1
there is no censoring we have a complete
data set
and in that case we're going to compute
a probability mass function a cumulative
distribution function a survival
function and a hazard function so i'm
going to define all of those things and
show you how we're going to compute them
and then in notebook 2 we will do the
more difficult problem of dealing with
censorship
or censoring i should say
okay if you're following in the slides
there's a link there that goes to the
notebook if you click on that
it should
run on colab
if you're not familiar with colab i'll
give you a couple of tips in just a
second but i also want to say that if
you go back to
the main
home page for the workshop the same link
is here this will open the notebook on
colab
now you have an option which is if you
want to follow along with me
i will demonstrate some things by typing
them and you can type along as well and
i think that this is a really good way
to learn because it will keep you
engaged and you are less likely to
re you're more likely to remember things
and less likely to tune out however if
that doesn't work for you if it's not a
good way to work and you prefer not to
do it you have the option here you can
click and get the complete notebook that
has everything that's already filled in
so it's up to you but i do recommend
that you play along and and type things
as we go
so let's get into the notebook
so this is a jupyter notebook running on
collab
colab is a service provided by google
that lets me upload a notebook and then
anybody
can run the notebook
what you are currently looking at is a
copy of the notebook that has been
copied from my github repository so the
first thing i want to tell you is that
uh you can do anything you want to this
notebook it will have no effect on me so
don't worry about breaking anything it's
totally fine
however this notebook is running in a
safe mode where it's not really saving
your work so what you might want to do
is come here
to the top middle of the page there's a
button that says copy to drive and if
you do that it will make a copy of this
notebook and put it in your google drive
assuming that you have one and then any
work that you do during this workshop
will be saved and you'll be able to come
back to it
in the worst case if you do lose it you
can pick up the complete notebook that i
was just showing okay
here's the other thing to know about uh
the notebook
it contains both text cells and code
cells so the first few are
text that introduces the topic
and introduces the first data set that
we're working with you can
use the up and down arrows to move
between cells you can also hold down the
shift button and press enter and that
will have the effect of executing the
current cell and then moving down to the
next one
so i'm going to give myself a little bit
more vertical space to work with here
and i'll introduce the first data set
that we'll use
which is the lifetime of light bulbs
that are on continuously and this was an
actual experiment that someone did they
got 50 light bulbs uh plug them all in
and ran them until they expired
what they did was they checked back
every 12 hours
and counted the number of light bulbs
that had gone out since the previous
visit
they recorded the data and it's
available on github
if you execute a couple more cells when
you get to the first cell that contains
code you will get this warning window
that tells you that this code was not
written by google and so it's not their
responsibility and that's fine you can
run it anyway
[Music]
this is running on the cloud it has very
limited ability to do harm to anything
so uh it's pretty safe
and
what the first cell does is downloads
the data file
and if that worked you should see a
message that says that lamps.csv
has been downloaded and saved
and then the next cell here
imports the libraries that we're going
to use which are pandas and numpy and pi
plot
and if you run the next cell it will
read the file
and put it into a pandas data frame
so i'm going to pause there and give you
all a chance to catch up and get the
notebook running
if you have any technical problems
you can either speak up now
or put a question into slack and i'm
going to slide away for just a second
and check the slack channel and see how
things are going
okay looks good so far
i will go on
so we have the data in hand and the
first thing that i want to do is
describe a probability mass function
that is the possible ages like how many
hours each light bulb might last
and the probability that a light bulb
will expire at that number of hours
and this data is available in the data
frame if you select df bracket f
so that's the column in the data frame
named f and what it contains is the
number of
light bulbs that had expired at each
time step
in this sequence
and what i want to do is make a new
panda series that contains both this
data which is the number of failures and
column h which is the number of hours
and i'm going to do that by creating a
pandas dot series
[Music]
using this as the data and i'm going to
extract the values
and then for the index i'm going to use
the other column which is df bracket h
if you are not familiar with pandas let
me give you a brief introduction
the series object is a sequence of
values
that also contains an index
so it represents the correspondence
between the index and the values
and in this case the index consists of
the number of hours
that the
experiment ran for
and the values in the right hand column
are the number of failures the number of
light bulbs that expired at that time
so i'm going to take this object and
assign it to a variable named pmf
and i'm going to do one other thing
which is i'm going to give the pmf
dot index a name
[Music]
and i'm going to call it t
just to be consistent with my notation
going forward
so now if i display
this pmf object let me just show the
first few lines using head
if i display the object what i see on
the left hand side is the index which is
called t
and on the right hand side the values
which are the
expiration dates the the times when the
light bulbs failed
now notice that the the failures are
integers they're counts this is the
number of light bulbs that failed
we can think of this thing as being a
distribution but normally we would make
the distribution add up to one so that
these values behave like probabilities
and we'll do that by normalizing the pmf
by dividing through by the sum
so if i add them up that'll be the total
number of light bulbs which happens to
be 50
and if i divide through
it the results are now normalized so
that the values are probabilities and if
we look
at the first few values
what they say what this says is that
about four percent of the light bulbs
expired at our number 840
about two percent expired at 852
and so on
so that's what a pmf is a pmf is a
mapping from possible outcomes to
probabilities in this case the outcomes
are the number of hours and the
probabilities are telling us what
fraction of light bulbs would expire at
a particular time
the
pmf one of the things that you can do
with a pmf is look up a particular time
and get the corresponding probability so
if you use the square brackets pmf
bracket 840 will tell you the
probability that's associated with our
840 and we've already seen that that's
about four percent
i'm going to show one other example
which is not super interesting but it
will make a little bit more sense when
we get to the next section we can also
look up for example 1524
and it turns out that about six percent
of the light bulbs expired after
1524 hours
okay
i have a couple of functions here that
i'm going to use to display results i
have a function called decorate that's
just a convenient way to put labels on
the axes
the details of that are not super
important but this is a way to visualize
what the pmf looks like it's just taking
the data from that pandas series and
plotting it as a line plot
now honestly this is not the best
visualization
of this data
but it shows one of the things about
pmfs that is not ideal which is that
they tend to be noisy
in a way that makes it difficult to see
exactly what's going on
so we do have a sense from looking at
this that most of the lifetimes are
between roughly a thousand and two
thousand hours
but from this figure alone we don't get
a very clear picture of what this
distribution looks like we're going to
do a lot better by using a cdf and
that's where we're headed next
so in the next section i'm going to take
this pmf and
compute its cdf and i'll explain what
that is if you're not familiar with them
i'll use this little triangle widget to
open up the next section
however before i go on i'm going to
pause again to check on slack and if you
have any
questions that you're stuck on feel free
to unmute and ask and then we'll go on
okay looks good i heard from at least
one person that says that the collab
notebook is working
i saw one question that asked about
continuous versus uh discrete
uh representations of these
distributions for survival analysis
everything that i'm going to do is
discrete in part because it's coming
from these relatively small data sets
but yes there is a continuous version of
everything that we're currently doing
my intention here is by showing you the
discrete version
i think in my opinion it's easier to
understand the concepts and then
when you go to the continuous version
the math becomes just a little bit more
advanced you've got you know integrals
and derivatives for example
but if you understand the concepts i
think it's not too much more difficult
so let's move on we've got a
distribution and we've represented it
with a pmf
the next thing we'll do is also
represent it with a cdf and
in terms of discrete mathematics it is
the continuous sorry the cumulative sum
of the probabilities that are in the pmf
so i'm going to create a new cdf thing
which is the pmf.cumulative
sum
and that is a pandas function that
computes cumulative sums
and if we look at the head
the first few values that are in the cdf
we can see that
these values
0.04 0.06 0.08 0.08.10
are the cumulative sums
from the
pmf
so
4 2 2 2 if you add it up becomes 4 6 8
10.
and that's what we have
in the cdf
so it doesn't seem like we've
changed much here
but this does two things for us and one
is that we can quickly compute the
fraction of light bulbs that expired at
or before any particular time so again
we can use square brackets to look up a
time stamp
and what it says is that four percent of
the light bulbs expired at or before 840
hours
that's not too interesting we kind of
knew that
[Music]
but we can also put in a value like 1524
and it'll tell us that 60 percent of the
light bulbs expired at or before 15 24
hours
so that's one thing the cdf does what
it's computing there is a percentile
it's telling us that the 60th percentile
is 15 24.
and the other thing that the cdf does is
it gives us a way to visualize the
distribution
that is not as noisy as the pmf
and so what we see here is very roughly
a sigmoid kind of shape
that says that there are very few light
bulbs that expire before 1 000 hours the
great majority of them if we read off 1
000 on the graph and come up to here
it looks like fewer than twenty percent
of the light bulbs die before one
thousand hours
however very few of them exceed
two thousand if we come up here and read
off 2000 what that's saying is that
let's say 95 percent of the light bulbs
have expired before 2000 hours
and in between it's a straight-ish line
so we could say that very approximately
this is a uniform distribution from
about a thousand to about two thousand
[Music]
okay
so far that might have been familiar to
you if you've taken a statistics class
you probably know about pmfs and cdfs
you might not know about survival curves
or survival functions
the mathematics of it couldn't be
simpler the survival function is just
the complement of the cdf
so if someone asks you for a survival
function you can just compute one minus
the cdf
and if you display it
survival dot head
this is the fraction of light bulbs that
exceed a given time t
so what this is saying is that 100 of
the light bulbs the fraction is 1.0
100 of the light bulbs lasted longer
than zero hours i should hope
uh 96 percent of them lasted longer than
840 hours
and so on
and again if you like you can use the
square brackets to look up a particular
value
like my favorite 1524
and that'll confirm that it is the
complement of the cdf so the cdf was 60
the survival function is 40
and if you plot both the survival
function
and the cdf you can visually see that
they are complements of each other
the difference is that the survival
function starts at 100
and comes down
the cdf goes the other direction
so nothing super profound going on here
um the only reason that survival
functions exist is partly um
convention that in in the domains where
we do survival analysis this is the
conventional way of showing
distributions um however it is also a
step toward the hazard function so if
you've got survival functions it is one
step easier to compute the hazard
function which is what we'll do next
but i will pause there once again i want
to check slag for questions and feel
free to unmute and ask if you've got
something
yes i see a question on slack that says
the pmf is not the cumulative
probability it is the instantaneous
probability of failure at a point in
time and that's correct now in this
particular experiment instantaneous
means these little 12-hour windows
during
where they checked the light bulbs so in
that sense the data have been uh
discretized by the nature of the
experiment
but yes so the pmf is an instantaneous
thing the cdf is the cumulative
uh probability of dying before a
particular time the survival function is
the probability of dying after a
particular time
and that's what gets us to the survival
rate or sorry the hazard function
the hazard rate
is the fraction of light bulbs that
survive until time t
and then fail at time t
so you can think of it as the
instantaneous danger like how much
danger are you in
if it's our number 1524
what's the probability that a light bulb
that has survived up until this point
will expire at exactly that point
and in order to compute this we need
both the pmf and the survival function
because the pmf tells us what fraction
of bulbs expired at t
and we'll we will use the survival
function to compute the fraction that
were alive at t
and it's going to be the sum of two
parts if we add the pmf and the survival
function
that will tell us how many light bulbs
were still burning at time t
the pmf tells us how many of them
expired at time t
and the ratio of those two things is the
hazard rate
so i've said it in words let me show it
to you in code it's almost simpler in
code
it is the pmf
divided by the sum of the pmf and the
survival function
and just to say one more time the
denominator here is the number of light
bulbs that we're still burning at time t
and the pmf is the is the fraction that
expired at exactly t
and so that what we are interested is
the ratio of those things
and here's what the head
of that looks like
so taking the first row or the first
interesting row what this is saying is
of all the light bulbs that survived
until our number 840
four percent of them died at that point
and maybe taking this one this says that
of all the light bulbs that survived
until 960
about two percent a little bit more
expired at that point
here's what this function looks like
[Music]
so this is a function of lifetime again
hours from zero up to about 2500
and this is the
probability that a light bulb will die
at this time given that it has survived
up until this time
and that's maybe another way of thinking
about it is it's like a conditional
probability
so looking at 1500 for example
this is given that you have survived
until fifteen hundred what's the
probability that you will expire at
fifteen hundred
now the hazard function has the same
problem that the pmf has which is it's
based on discrete data and it tends to
be pretty noisy
and so not easy to see what the shape of
the curve
looks like
however there's a little bit of a trick
that people do
which is to plot
the
cumulative hazard function
[Music]
and here's what that looks like i'm
using the cumulative sum function again
so this is the same way that we computed
the cdf
and plotting the cumulative hazard and
it has the same effect it is
smoothing out the noise
and showing a little bit more clearly
what's happening
where
however the vertical axis now is a
little bit hard to interpret because
this is the sum of a rate
which in mathematical terms doesn't
really mean very much so
don't pay too much attention to the
values on the y-axis
the four
for example doesn't really tell us much
of anything
however we can tell from looking at this
curve where it's steep and where it's
shallow because when it's steep that
means that a lot of light bulbs were
dying in that range that means that the
hazard function is high
and where the slope here is low that
means that the hazard function is low so
if we look at this part of the curve
from about 1 000 hours to 2000 hours
it has positive curvature it has
increasing slope
and what that tells us is that it is an
increasing hazard function
so
it starts out slow
meaning that the hazard is relatively
low between 1000 and 1500 hours
and then it is steep here and that means
that the hazard function is higher
between 1500 and 2000 hours
so that's the hazard function
and the cumulative
hazard function
let me again pause i'm going to check
slack and feel free to unmute if you
have a question
so um quick one so has a function is
that on
in general like the average of all the
observations
or is it
something else because i could i scroll
down slightly and you're doing it for
each observation as well
yes um
[Music]
are you talking about the next section
here where i'm resampling
um
possibly uh
okay
let me get to that in just a second and
i think i'm i'm not positive i
understand the question but let me say
something and see if it helps
which is
um
this curve is based on the entire data
set so
when i'm doing all of these
pandas operations
it's doing them element wise on the
whole pmf
so
it's computing for the whole data set at
once did that answer your question
yeah yeah i think i was
reading too quickly and not really
understanding gadget
fast and i hope things are making sense
we are going to go for just a couple
more minutes to finish this notebook and
then we're going to take a break for
five minutes and i hope that that will
give you a chance to take a breath
look at what we've done so far and ask
more questions if you have them
okay at this point we have computed all
the things that we're going to compute
i'm going to do one thing in the next
section which is to
think about what parts of this curve are
reliable
and which parts are probably like
statistically noisy
and one way to think about this if we
look at the left hand side of this curve
nearly all of the light bulbs
were still burning at 500 hours and what
that means is that the sample size here
is about 50. almost 50 light bulbs were
worn and and that means that it's
probably pretty reliable
if we go to the other end of the thing
this data point all the way at the end
is based on a single light bulb that
happened to last for more than 2500
hours
so in some sense the sample size on the
right-hand part of this curve is one
which means that from a statistical
point of view it's not very reliable
and that's one of the things to look at
in the next section
is to get a sense of how much
variability there is
in
these functions
because of random sampling
and i'm going to do this by a resampling
process
if you're not familiar with resampling
this might make your head hurt just a
little bit
but here's what i'm going to do i'm
going to take the actual data
and i'm going to use kernel density
estimation to make a model for the
distribution so this is like a smooth
version of the distribution
and then i'm going to use the resample
function to draw a new synthetic sample
from that model
so again i'm using the data to build a
model and then i'm using the model to
generate lots of synthetic data sets and
you can think of these as like alternate
universes
this is what the data set could have
been if i had sampled it differently if
i had got a different set of 50 light
bulbs
and what i'm going to do for each
synthetic data set i'm going to do 100
i'm going to do 100 fake data sets and
for each one i'm going to do the
complete computation
that we have done so far
that's what this function does i have a
function here that is called make hazard
and what it does is it computes the pmf
of the
synthetic sample the fake data
then it computes the cdf the survival
function and the hazard
so this is kind of like everything we've
done so far stuffed into one function
and it returns all four of them
so what this loop does
let's take a look at it i'm going to do
that 100 times oh go ahead
i thought i heard a question
yes go ahead please
okay quite a bit if you want to put
something in the slack we can do that
too
so again just to explain what this is
doing
i'm going to run it a hundred times
contrary to what the what the comment
says run it a hundred times generate a
fake sample compute the
all of the functions compute the
survival function and plot it
so i'm gonna plot a hundred gray lines
and then the blue line is the actual
data
and you can think of this as a visual
confidence interval
that's telling you how much different
the data could have been
if i ran the same experiment again
under the assumptions of my model
and this gives us a sense of how
statistically precise
the estimate is for this survival
function and what it's showing is that
it's reasonably good over the whole
range
of the survival function
if we do exactly the same thing
for the hazard function
it answers the question that i posed a
minute ago which is what parts of this
curve are reliable and what parts are
more statistically noisy
and it pretty much goes from left to
right so this is like a cone of
uncertainty that gets bigger because as
we move to the right hand side
we're losing sample size
and by the time we get to the last few
data points it is statistically very
noisy
so that is the end of the first notebook
i'm going to do a quick review and then
we will take our break but let me before
i leave the notebook any questions
that i should answer here
uh yeah i do have uh two yes
okay so uh the first one was already
posted on slack and uh it is um when you
uh build the um
basically the hazard function
and um
you uh you show the head of the data
frame you refer to
the point that were sampled as
percentages
so um
should should we assume that the uh
hazard function is a
probability distribution
good question
yes and no
so it is not a distribution function
because those
rates
do not add up to one
okay so each of them is a different rate
and in fact we we know what they add up
to because that's what the cumulative
hazard function is so it turns out in
this example that they add up to four
and that doesn't mean anything except
that it's not one
and what this is saying is
each rate
is a percentage
it is the percentage of light bulbs that
live up until time t and die at time t
ooh let me say that a little bit
differently it is the fraction of all
the light bulbs that survive until t it
is the fraction that die at t
so
you can think of it as a probability but
the hazard function is not a probability
distribution because it doesn't add up
to one
okay cool thank you and the
uh let's go ahead
the second question uh is instead of uh
related to the kernel density estimate
and it is a
side of practical purposes uh which is
in a gaussian kde does this put any
assumption on the distribution on the
distribution of the data is it related
or
just uh
because
right right i used kde you're right that
it makes an assumption it does not
assume that the distribution is gaussian
it only assumes that the distribution is
somewhat smooth
and in this case i think it's a
reasonable assumption so uh i think kde
is making a very weak constraint on the
model
okay so that that is also that we could
use basically any other
any other uh
density estimate like even a poisson or
yes um
probably it yeah the for for what i'm
doing here the particular choice of the
model is not going to have a strong
effect
um i could even just do discrete
resampling i could uh draw a sample from
the original data without doing any
smoothing at all and that would work too
okay cool thank you doc
sure
good all right
i'm going to jump back to the slides for
a second
and because i just wanted to show this
figure this is a summary of everything
that we just did
we started with a sample we computed the
pmf
although in the lightbulb example they
had sort of already computed it for us
we computed the pmf we did the
cumulative sum to get the cdf
we did the complement to get the
survival function
and then
to get the hazard function it's
basically division because we're
computing a rate
and then we also computed the cumulative
hazard as a way of visualizing the
hazard rate
and that is the first half so
congratulations you have survived
um
i'll say one quick thing which is that
all of these
representations are equivalent in the
sense that if you are given any of them
you can compute all of the others
now the reason that it's useful to have
different distributions is that they can
answer different questions and we showed
that in the notebook i review it a
little bit here in the slides but i
think i won't present these if you'd
like you could read that during the
break and let me know if you have
questions
because i do want to make sure that we
take a break
so we'll come back in five minutes when
the dancing animals have stopped dancing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's still a little bit too loud
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank
so
alan uh i wanted to let you know you're
an unpopular name in my house
i i i just had my my first child
and i was reading um your think stats
while my partner was waiting to
go into labor and she was very upset
that uh i told her week 39
there was a 50
chance uh that the child would be born
that week and at uh week 40 it wouldn't
increase it would still be 50
that's correct that is the cruelest
curve in survival analysis
yeah yeah and so she told me to stop
reading um
uh think stats
and start doing things to help the baby
come out
well congratulations oh yeah thanks did
come and at what week
uh week 40 yeah halfway through already
yeah yeah that's long
yeah well there was a 40 50 chance oh no
50 50 chance once we had arrived at 40
of course that was
yes yeah yeah yes my second child was
several weeks late
and uh eventually required a little bit
of uh incentive
[Music]
okay i think the dancing animals are
done
and let us get back to it
so just again to summarize what we have
so far we have several ways to represent
a distribution
and we know how to compute them going in
the forward direction and now here's the
key to the second part which is so all
of this what we've done so far depends
on having a representative sample
meaning among other things no sensoring
if we have sensor data
we're going to use kaplan-buyer
estimation this is one of several
methods but it is one that i think is is
the foundation it gives you the clearest
picture of what's going on
the key idea of kaplan-meier estimation
is that instead of starting from the pmf
and going forward we are going to start
from the hazard function and go backward
so
here's the forward direction this is
what we just did in notebook one
here is the reverse direction this is
what we're going to do in notebook two
we'll start with a sample and directly
estimate the hazard function
and then from there we will go backwards
to do the survival
cdf and pmf curves
that is the plan
and that is the outline if you follow
this link you'll get into notebook 2
or again if you go back to the home page
for the workshop you can also follow the
link from here
and just as a reminder if at any point
you get lost or you don't want to play
along anymore you can go to the complete
notebook and view it on nb viewer
but let's jump back into or jump into
notebook 2.
so this is the notebook on kaplan-meyer
estimation
and
again when you start the notebook the
first code cell that you run is going to
give you a warning
we're going to import
the libraries
now for this example i'm going to use
completely fabricated data i'm just
going to make up some numbers but to
give them some context you could imagine
an experiment where you want to know how
long it takes for a dog to get adopted
from a shelter
so if you have an observation window of
10 weeks
you might record the arrival time for
every dog that arrives during your
observation window
and the adoption time for the dogs that
were adopted
but at the end of your observation
window there might be some dogs who are
still in the shelter they haven't been
adopted yet
you know how long they've been there but
you don't know how long it will be until
they're adopted so those cases will be
right censored
and here's how i'm going to represent
that
i'm going to create a data frame
with three columns it has the start time
the end time and the status
so start time is when the dog arrives at
the shelter
end is when the dog was either
adopted
or
this is how many weeks the dog had been
there
at the end of the observation period and
the status column indicates which one it
is
so if static status equals 1 that means
that the dog was adopted if status
equals two that means that the dog was
still at the shelter at the end of the
observation period
that's the data frame
and i've got a function here
if you enjoy matplotlib you might like
the details but
what it does is it generates a plot that
looks like this
and these are called lifelines
and they represent in this case the life
of the dog meaning
from the time that it arrives in the
shelter until the time that it leaves
the shelter
and again there are two kinds of cases
the orange lines end with a dot and that
means an adoption
and the blue lines end at the end of the
observation window and so that means
that that dog had not been adopted at
the time that we stopped watching
the vertical axis here is just an index
for you know dog number zero dog number
one dog number two
and so if you read this you would say
okay dog number zero
arrived during week zero and was adopted
uh during week five
and if you go down dog number three
arrived at week two and it was still in
the shelter at the end of week nine
which was the end of the observation
so here's what we're going to do we want
to estimate the survival curve and we're
going to do this by computing
the hazard function
and let me show you how we're going to
do that we're going to sneak up on it
gradually
i just need to get my notes
all right
the first thing i'm going to do is
separate out the what i'm going to call
the complete cases from the incomplete
cases so complete means that we know the
adoption time and incomplete means we
don't because the dog was still in the
shelter so i'm going to pull out
complete
and it's going to be
the duration
and
back up i think i need to compute
duration
all right
[Music]
so i'm going to pull out
the durations
[Music]
and this will be the difference between
the two columns so i've got my
observations
and i have the end
minus
the observed
start
so that'll be my duration
and i'm going to display that
okay
so the duration for dog zero was five
weeks the duration for dog one was one
week and so on
now i want to pull out
the complete ones
so complete is going to be the durations
and as an index i'm going to use the
observation
that the status
is equal to one
so this term
that will be true for the dogs that
are complete when status is one and
it'll select only those durations
so complete
will be a subset of the durations
five one four and two
and ongoing those are my incomplete
cases will be the durations
duration
in the case where the status
[Music]
is zero and we can see what those values
are
okay
so i've partitioned the data set into
two
two chunks the durations for the
complete observations and the incomplete
observations
let me that was a lot of typing so i'm
going to leave that up on the screen for
just a second and make sure that you
have a chance to catch up
oh and one other thing i didn't mention
again if you want to make sure that your
changes are being saved you might want
to press that save to drive button up at
the top
okay
so i've separated out my complete cases
from my ongoing cases
and now i'm going to make a different
pmf for each of them
right
okay
sorry i've i've
messed up a little bit here and so i
need us to go backwards
i have put the wrong code into the wrong
section so some of this is exactly what
we need we do need duration i'm going to
take this code
and copy it into the next section
and we'll come back to it in a minute
and i'm going to delete this code for a
minute
because i just did the wrong thing here
so sorry let me back up
there's another key step here that i've
skipped so let me be a little bit more
careful i was rushing and messed things
up
there are two key ideas that we need to
fix and one of them is
all of these dogs arrived and departed
at different times
in order to make them more comparable to
each other we're going to take all of
these lifelines and shift them to the
left as if all of the dogs had arrived
during week zero
and this isn't going to change any of
the durations it's just going to
line them up so that rather than using
clock time like what week it is of the
year we're going to use relative time
like how long have they been in the
shelter
and i'm going to do that
by making a copy
of the observation
notebook
uh data frame
so i'm gonna make a copy
of this
and i'm gonna change all of the start
change all of the start column to zero
so it's as if all the dogs arrived
during week zero
and
all of the end
durations
although the end times are equal to the
durations
okay
and we can see what that looks like
shifted dot shifted rack
dot head
[Music]
shifted
[Music]
all right
so again i'll give you a second to catch
up with the typing
i computed the duration for each dog
i created a copy of the observation data
frame
i shifted it so all the start times are
zero
of the end times are equal to the
durations
and the status column is the same
and now if you plot
lifelines
which is the same function that we used
before
and you plot the shifted values
it should look pretty much the same
except that all the lifelines are now
starting at week 0.
so i'll put that code up
and give you a second to type any
questions on this again i'm sorry about
the confusion
so that's the first key idea is to take
all the lifelines and shift them so they
start at zero
and then the second key idea is to
compute the hazard rate
by considering
how many dogs were there that could have
been adopted at each time stamp
and how many of them actually were
adopted at each time stamp
and the idea here is
at risk we would say that a dog is at
risk if it was available for adoption
during a particular time
so if we look at the figure starting at
week zero
there were seven dogs at week zero
that could have been adopted and none of
them were adopted instantly so there are
no dots at week zero
if you look at the next vertical column
in this figure starting here
there are still seven dogs available and
one of them is adopted
so the hazard rate at time one is one
out of seven
if you look at the next time stamp
time stamp two
now there are only six dogs that were
still observable
during week two
and one of them was adopted so the
hazard rate at week two is one out of
six
and that's how we're going to get the
hazard rate out of this diagram
by computing the number of dogs who were
at risk during each time step
and the number who were actually adopted
during each time step
um i got a quick question if you
yes please
i posted in the slack but i was curious
the um in order to
shift the data and perform this analysis
uh i
i it sounds like we're making the
assumption that uh adoption of dogs is
not um impacted by effects like
seasonality are there other sorts of
assumptions that we're making about this
data or is that a true assessment of
this uh
analysis
that is correct that's a great point and
thank you for making it you're
absolutely right so we're assuming that
the actual time in the world doesn't
matter and that means that adoption
rates are considered to be constant in
this model
uh that they they might depend on how
long the dog has been in the shelter but
they don't depend on what the calendar
date is
so
does that mean that seasonal
so is there a version of survival
analysis that takes into effect things
like seasonality yes absolutely and
that's um we're not going to do
regression models today but there is
there are regression models that work
for this kind of data and i will i'll
point you to them as a resource but
that's an example where that would let
you explore whether there are external
factors that affect the hazard rate
and a seasonal effect or you know any
kind of external time is that time
effect
would would be
you could include that in the bottle
okay all right thank you very much sure
okay
all right now we're ready to do what i
started to do before which is to break
the data set up into two parts for the
complete and incomplete observations
we started to do this a minute ago so
you might already have this code
but i'll just bring it up to date so the
ongoing
will be the ones where the status is
equal to zero
there are four dogs that were observed
being adopted and three that were still
in the shelter
at the end and i've got this make pmf
function
that's going to compute separate pmfs
for the two cases so i'll have a pmf
for the complete cases
by running make
pmf
on the complete
data
and a pmf
ongoing
using make
pmf
for the ongoing data
and i think they're not particularly
interesting looking
pmfs
[Music]
now one note i'm calling these things
pmfs although for this example i'm not
going to normalize them i could and the
whole computation would work if i if i
normalized them it would be the same i
just think it's a little bit easier to
keep them as counts
because that's going to let me
i don't know i just think it's easier to
keep track of what's going on
now i've got these two pmfs i'm going to
put them together into a data frame
because this is going to let us see each
step of the computation as it goes along
so i'm going to create a dictionary
and i'm going to put into the dictionary
the two pmfs that i just created
so pmf complete equals pmf complete
and
pmf
ongoing
equals pms
ongoing
the reason i'm making a dictionary is
that it's a convenient way to make a
data frame
but i need an index
so the index is going to be the union of
the two indices
pmf complete
dot union
pmf
ongoing and i'm going to extract the
index from each one
now this is a little bit of panda's
magic
so if you're not familiar with pandas
and indices this might be
a little weird but let me show you the
result and then i think the process will
make more sense i'm going to create a
data frame
called pd.data frame
that has the dictionary as the values
and that index that i just created
as the
index
and i'll display it
and this has allowed me to put the two
pmfs
into
the same data frame
and to line them up
so that the index the column on the left
hand side
these are the week numbers
this is telling me that during week one
there was one dog that was adopted
during week two there was one dog that
was adopted and one dog that was
observed at week two and then left the
observation window
and i'm doing all of this because what
this is going to allow me to do is
compute the number of dogs who were at
risk
during each week and the fraction of
them that were adopted
now i'm going to do one more thing which
is a filner fill n a which is i'm going
to replace the not a number
values with zero
and that is that
so let me put that code up on the screen
give you all a chance to catch up i'm
going to check slack and then we'll go
on
i have a question if i may
yeah go ahead please yeah this might be
sort of similar to
the seasonality
assumption earlier on but
are we also assuming that each dog's uh
like process is uh probabilistically
independent from every other dog's
process
like i don't know if shelter gets super
full either like for lower probability
or higher probability than
that a dog gets adopted for example
right
yes this model is making the assumption
that the dogs don't affect each other
um so right i think you you just gave an
example where yeah if there are a lot of
dogs then
the probability for each dog might be a
little bit lower
and so that's
in this example the model might not be
completely realistic
thank you
okay
[Music]
so i don't want to get too bogged down
in the computation here where we're
headed again is we're going to compute
the number of dogs at risk
and in order to do that i'm also going
to compute the survival functions
and again what i'm going to do is
compute the cdf
which is the cumulative sum of the pmf
and also the
complement so once i've got the cdf i
compute the complement and that's the
survival and i'm going to add this as an
additional column in the table
so df
bracket i'm going to call it s
underscore complete
this will be the survival function for
the complete cases is going to be the
make
serve function
passing in
the pmf that we computed from the table
so df pmf complete
and make sure that you get the version
that comes from the table because it has
been
stretched a little bit because of the
new index
and if you visualize that
table
you can see what we're doing here so
we're adding a new column to the table
that is the
survival function for the complete cases
and i will also add the survival
function for the ongoing cases
now why is this useful
if i add up these four columns that is
the number of dogs who are at risk
because the number of dogs who could be
adopted during a given week is the sum
of
all the ones that
survived to that point and got adopted
all the ones that survived at that point
and left the observation window all the
ones that survived survived past that
point which is the survival
curve
and were either adopted or not
so the sum of these four columns is the
number of dogs who are at risk
and so i can add that df bracket at
risk
is
[Music]
df.sum
and i'm going to sum along the
horizontal axis which is axis one
and
oh rats i spelled it wrong i'm gonna i'm
gonna leave it spelled wrong rather than
add two columns but you should spell it
right
now i'm gonna fix it hang on
at
wrist
okay and now i'm going to df
delete
df bracket
bar
[Music]
let's see if i've got it fixed
there we go
all right
now we know how many dogs were at risk
during each week
yes
i think the sum doesn't add up no no
it's yours
yes you are correct uh what has happened
there
let me i think you have to delete the
column before you sum yes i'm gonna just
back up and create the data frame again
from the top but yes you're right i had
an extra column in there and then i
computed the sum several times
and so i ended up with extra stuff
there we go that's better
all right now i know how many dogs were
at risk during each week
and pmf complete is the number that were
adopted during each week and so the
hazard df bracket hazard
is the ratio of those two things
it's df bracket pmf complete
divided by
df bracket at
risk
and i'll display it
there we go
so one more time i'll pause for just a
second give you a chance to catch up
i'll check slack
looks good
all right
and just a reminder where we are here
we're doing this so we've just done the
first step which is to take the sample
and compute the hazard function
that was the hard part
and everything else now is just to take
the things that we did before
and
do them in the opposite direction
so given the hazard function we're going
to compute the survival function the cdf
and the pmf
and that's what's in the next section
[Music]
so let me show you the computation and
then i'll explain why it is what it is
df bracket serve
the survival function
is going to be one minus the hazard
function
[Music]
so the hazard function tells you if i'm
alive at time t what's the probability
of dying at time t or in this case
adoption if i'm still in the kennel at
time t what's the probability of being
adopted so the compliment is the
probability of not being adopted
so if i'm not adopted at time 0 and i'm
not adopted at time 1 and i'm not
adopted at time 2
the probability is the product
of each of those
and so if i take this
hazard function
compute the complement and then compute
the cumulative product
that will be the survival function
that is my chance of making it past all
of these gates
so you can think of each of them as
being a gate where i have some
probability of surviving
and the cumulative product
is the probability of surviving past all
the gates
once i have the survival function
i can compute the cdf which is the
complement
of the survival function
and display the data frame
and once i have the cdf i can make the
pmf
now remember that the cdf is the
cumulative sum
so to go in the other direction i'm
going to use diff
and i'm going to use np.diff and this is
a little bit of a hack
rather than using pandas i'm using np
and the reason is that it does something
for me
[Music]
i can compute the difference of the cdf
and i can prepend
a zero and that causes it to
do the computation correctly
i want the labor of the detail there
and that's it that's the whole process
so we did a fair amount of work to get
to at-risk
but once we had that we computed the
hazard the survival the cdf and the pmf
now how are we doing out there
is the is is the pre-pen something like
fill n a zero um if you would do it with
diff
um on the pandas yeah so what what it
does is it it takes the sequence and it
puts a zero at the beginning and then it
computes the diffs
and for this particular case going from
a cdf to a pnf that's exactly what we
want to do
so for weeks where no daw was adopted it
just doesn't have any data basically
yes so it's treating the hazard function
as
kind of like a delta function
where it's zero everywhere and then it
has values at these particular points in
time
i'm a little bit confused about
something i may have missed something
early in this
jupiter notebook
but uh
why are we
doing this backwards analysis
instead of just repeating the same
analysis we had before
yes
so the problem is that this only works
if the sample is unbiased
meaning that it doesn't have any
censoring
i see so if we if all the cases are
complete cases
like if we follow the dogs until they're
adopted
then we could do the forward process
when we have missing data when we have
the censored data that's when we have to
do this
okay i see
all right thank you good
all right
the next section of the notebook i
believe we don't have to do any typing
for this one but we do have to install
lifelines so if you run this cell it
will install this library it's pip
installable it's pure python so it's a
pretty clean installation
and
hi i have a question too hello yes go
ahead please
um in real life scenario do you think uh
we we are most often we most often find
ourselves in the censored situation i'm
thinking like a business where i have
not had a chance to observe every
customer for let's say five years of uh
lifetime value
right then i'm looking at a censored set
of observations and i have to predict
whether this customer will last or not
so in most real world situations are we
all
would you say we are dealing with this
sort of sensor data
yes yeah exactly for the reason that you
just said which is that very often what
you want to do is use all the data up
until the present
in order to make a prediction for the
next you know week month whatever it is
and what that means is that you're
almost always working with right
censored data
got it thank you
sure and that maybe brings you back to
the beginning where we said that this is
a vastly under-appreciated
method and i think that's exactly the
reason which is this you this this kind
of data censorship is extremely common
now i'm getting close to the end of time
and i do want to make sure that we end
at at the correct time
so
let me summarize a couple things and
then we'll have maybe just a minute for
questions
um again we we have several different
ways to represent distributions and they
are equivalent in the sense that if you
are given any of them you can compute
all of the others
and then the second notebook we did
kaplan-meier estimation and that's the
case when the data are right-censored we
can estimate the hazard function and use
it to compute all of the
others
now
we got the question earlier is
what if there are external factors that
affect the hazard rate and for that you
want regression methods that would allow
you to estimate the hazard
as a function of all of these external
factors
and for that i will point you to
lifelines which i skipped in the
notebook but you can continue that
section if you go to the complete
uh notebook what it shows is that the
kaplan buyer estimator that is built
into lifelines computes exactly the same
result that we just computed so it works
it has a very nice section the
documentation here i think is very good
and in particular the section about
survival regression that is i believe
your next stop after this workshop you
should go read that
um if you enjoyed this you might also
like think stats this is based on one of
the chapters from think stats
and my most recent project is the second
edition of think baze which just came
out a couple of months ago if you're
interested in bayesian statistics you
could consult that
and then last i wanted to give you this
this is on the five ways to get in touch
with me
uh including my blog my blog which is
called
probably overthinking it
and so if you enjoyed this you might
like some of the articles there
and let me take a breath
see if you have any questions and then
we'll wrap up
um i just have a general question if i
may
um
so it's been a while since i've been in
a you know formal probability course but
um at least the kind of problem that he
has to tackle
uh to me seems like it's reminiscent of
the like intro stochastic processes
uh that as you know when they first
introduced it to students as a you know
bernoulli opposing processes time until
light bulb goes off the type of things
like what are what is the
i don't know
maybe like a academic genealogy link uh
or like topic of overlap or maybe
comparative uh kind of critical
comparative um
idea here how do the two
spaces relate
right
yes there are lots of connections um
[Music]
let me i i won't have a coherent answer
off the top of my head but let me give
one example
so thinking about our bernoulli process
for example which is a bunch of coin
tosses where the coin tosses are
independent right
there's one very simple model uh like a
survival model that says i'm going to
toss coins until i get heads and i'll
record the total number of coin tosses
that i needed in order to get heads
and if you do that then the distribution
of lifetimes will be i think geometric
if it's discrete and exponential if it's
continuous
and that would be analogous to a
survival process where the hazard
function is a constant
in other words the probability of
getting heads is the same for every coin
toss
but you could also imagine a similar
kind of experiment where
it's a biased coin and the bias
increases over time so every time you
toss heads
every time you toss the coin the
probability of heads goes up
that would be like a hazard function
that's increasing like the light bulbs
so the light bulbs had an increasing
hazard function
and there are other examples in the real
world where the hazard function might go
down over time
or one of the most common is a bathtub
shape
which is many things are likely like if
you think manufactured parts for example
if there's a manufacturing defect they
would tend to fail right away and so the
hazard function is high
but if you get through the initial
burn-in period then it's low for a while
and then eventually the part wears out
and the hazard function increases again
so i think that's my best attempt to
create a connection
between stochastic processes and this
kind of survival analysis
it's almost as if
uh it's introduced survival analysis and
produces an extra flexibility
around the assumption which is really
the assumption between you know
bernoulli and also poison processes of
constant probability across time
right right so this this models
situations where the hazard function can
vary in time in arbitrarily complicated
ways i see okay that's helpful thank you
good thank you
it is exactly one o'clock so i should
stop on time but if you do have other
questions that i didn't answer feel free
to jump over to slack and i'll stick
around for a little bit and answer
questions there
thank you all very much i hope it was
useful to you and feel free to be in
touch if i can help with anything thank
you bye-bye
uh thank you alan uh and uh
so there's one more thing i would like
to say the session is being recorded and
it would be uploaded on the website
latest by today evening
so you can keep an eye on that and the
link would be on the events page fighter
dot org slash global 2021 slash events
just below the zoom link of this session
so you could just re-watch it or you
know again and alan if you could just
please upload any slides or notebooks if
you could i think you have already did
that right if i'm not wrong
yes the landing page for the workshop
has everything and it will also have the
video once the video is available
awesome awesome yeah so that brings us
to the end of the session uh thank you
alan and thank you everyone for joining
us today